so behind me is a sign pointing to the
number of days until the opening
ceremony of the Olympic Games on July
24th here in Tokyo the Japanese
government has stepped up measures to
prevent the spread of the corona virus
Tokyo expects hundreds of thousands of
people from all across the world when it
holds the Olympics in less than five
months the next couple of weeks are
critical in keeping this virus in check
and preventing any kind of large-scale
outbreaks or clusters from developing at
say a concert or a school where you
might get hundreds of people in fact it
most schools across Japan are closed
some cherry blossom festivals are
canceled then the Tokyo marathon went
ahead with only 200 runners instead of
the more than 30,000 participants it
usually draws Prime Minister Robbie and
everybody his government wants to make
sure that the virus is cleared away and
not a major problem so that the Olympics
can go ahead as scheduled the
postponement or cancellation of the
games would be a massive blow to Japan
it has spent seven years planning and 20
billion dollars on preparations in order
to keep the games going
Tokyo has to prove that it can stop the
spread of the disease especially after
having been criticized for its handling
of the corona virus outbreak on a cruise
ship that was docked at Yokohama more
than 700 people got infected aboard the
diamond Princess and six have died so
far Tokyo said it did its best to
prevent the spread of the disease that's
not the only criticism Japan has faced
the number of tests being conducted
every day in Japan is about 900 or a
thousand a day recently whereas for
example in South Korea thousands and
tens of thousands of tests are being
conducted every day
Ave says there are now 4,000 test kits
available every day - the diamond
princess patience there have been about
300 cases in Japan so far Japan at the
moment appears to have the virus under
control but maybe the addition of more
tests will reveal that there are more
virus cases than we thought particularly
because the virus is no longer linked to
people who came from overseas virus
epicenters such as China Italy or Iran
in the last couple of weeks it's become
clear that it's spreading
independently in parts of Japan
especially in Hokkaido in northern Japan
and so a clearly a stepped-up response
was needed the government hopes the new
measures will help avert an outbreak
such as the one in neighboring South
Korea and help set the stage for the
Olympic Games it also needs to reassure
the public that it's taking all the
needed steps to stop the virus there is
the political or you might say
psychological benefits that Prime
Minister Abe a is clearly counting on
here in the sense that he wants to show
that he's a decisive leader he's not
taking this lightly that he's doing
whatever it takes to stop this virus
from spreading